[Applauso]
da sempre la scienza all'obiettivo di
andare oltre le frontiere della
conoscenza del sapere svelandoci misteri
della vita e del mondo che ci circonda
curiosità passione scoperta dell'ignoto
rappresentano il motore che spinge lo
scienziato andare alla ricerca del nuovo
lo scienziato infatti è colui che
osserva il mondo da angolazioni diverse
non si pone limiti delle saper osare e
sperimentare cose nuove ma soprattutto
delle porsi grandi domande il mondo
della mia ricerca e quello della
robotica bio è spirata
prendiamo ispirazione dalla natura per
carpirne i segreti e tradurli nuove
macchine nuova tecnologia più
sostenibile e utile all'uomo
viviamo infatti nell'era dei robot che
ad oggi realizzano la maggior parte dei
beni di utilizzo delle società moderne
ma che sempre di più si sposteranno dal
mondo delle fabbriche al mondo reale nel
nostro mondo condividendo i nostri spazi
ma quanto siamo davvero lontani da un
uso quotidiano e di massa e dei robot
così come è avvenuto per le tecnologie
dell'informazione e della comunicazione
negli ultimi 20 anni del 900 quando
abbiamo assistito ad un passaggio dai
laboratori universitari alle fabbriche
ad un computer in ogni casa e più
recentemente ha uno smartphone in ogni
tasca
ebbene i robot sono già in mezzo a noi
ma hanno forme diverse da quelle che
siamo abituati a vedere nei film di
fantascienza dove automi e replicanti
dalle capacità superiori a quelle umane
rappresentano una seria minaccia per la
sopravvivenza dell'umanità stessa
i robot saranno nelle nostre case ci
aiuteranno nelle attività domestiche e
l'assistenza agli anziani saranno utili
nel monitoraggio dell'ambiente del cibo
per il miglioramento della qualità della
vita della salute sempre di più saranno
utilizzati in campo medico ad esempio
nello sviluppo di nuovi endoscopi ma
anche micro robot che si muoveranno
all'interno del nostro corpo per
diagnosi e terapia macchine autonome che
ridurranno drasticamente il numero degli
incidenti stradali salvando vite umane e
restituendoci parte del nostro tempo
ma la vera rivoluzione in questo campo è
dato dalla robotica ispirata alla natura
gli organismi viventi sono adattate a
vivere in ambienti mutevoli e dinamici
devono mettere in atto delle strategie
in caso di pericolo nelle strategie per
sopravvivere riescono a percepire
l'ambiente circostante e tutte queste
caratteristiche sono assolutamente utili
rappresentano le nostre specifiche per
progettare i robot di domani i robot che
vivranno insieme a noi
molti sono infatti i robot già bio
ispirati realizzati dai laboratori di
ricerca di tutto il mondo e da aziende
robot che sono in grado di volare
correre camminare nuotare
la maggior parte di questi robot sono
ispirati al mondo degli animali vengono
chiamati anima loi di o umanoidi quando
il modello è l'essere umano quindi
studiamo l'essere umano per realizzare
dei robot umanoidi che sempre di più
condivideranno i nostri spazi ci
aiuteranno nell'assistenza agli anziani
ma anche rappresentano delle piattaforme
per i neuro scienziati per studiare il
modello di sviluppo di comportamento
dell'uomo ma perché fermarsi agli
animali per la prima volta a livello
mondiale io il mio gruppo abbiamo
pensato alle piante
come modello in robotica per sviluppare
delle nuove tecnologie delle nuove
macchine che noi chiamiamo plan toy di
alle piante infatti è demandata la
sopravvivenza sulla terra attraverso la
produzione dell'ossigeno rappresentano
la quasi totalità della biomassa sul
nostro pianeta hanno colonizzato tutti
gli ecosistemi
tuttavia non è stato facile far
accettare alla comunità scientifica
l'idea che una pianta potesse
rappresentare un modello e robotica e
molto babilmente questa è dovuta
l'opinione comune che tutti noi abbiamo
nei confronti delle piante le piante
sono organismi passivi non comunicano
non si muovono non interagiscono con
l'ambiente con altri esseri viventi
esiste una sorta di pregiudizio nei
confronti delle piante che fonda le sue
basi nell'antichità aristotele nel suo
trattato de anima sosteneva che le
piante non sono dotate di capacità
sensoriali perché non sono in grado di
muoversi lo stesso carlo linneo grande
scienziato al quale dobbiamo la
classificazione moderna degli organismi
viventi nutriva un forte pregiudizio nei
confronti delle piante ea john ellis
altro noto naturalista dell'epoca che
descriveva la dion è uscito la la venere
acchiappamosche come una perfetta
trappola per topi in miniatura carlo
linneo rispondeva l'idea che una pianta
sia in grado di intrappolare ed uccidere
insetti e assolutamente contro l'ordine
naturale voluto da dio
impossibile invertire lo stato delle
cose ed accettare che un vegetale possa
nutrirsi di un animale allora capite che
il pregiudizio influenza le nostre
opinioni
i nostri comportamenti in tutti i campi
incluso quello scientifico limitando le
frontiere della conoscenza
luce lo stesso jade darwin grande
scienziato fu vittima del pregiudizio e
fu costretto a cambiare il titolo del
suo trattato da piante carnivore a
piante insettivore per evitare le
critiche della comunita scientifica che
non riteneva etica tale denominazione ma
le piante le piante si muovono lo fanno
in maniera assolutamente efficiente lo
fanno a delle velocità che spesso non
sono percepibili dal nostro occhio e
quindi grazie alle nuove tecnologie
soprattutto basate su tecniche di time
laps è possibile accelerare il movimento
e quindi adesso godere appieno della
bellezza dei movimenti delle piante
le piante percepiscono l'ambiente lo
fanno attraverso distribuite capacità
sensoriali le piante comunicano
comunicano con altre piante ad esempio
in caso di pericolo comunicano con
animali funghi batteri
tutte queste caratteristiche e molte
altre ad esempio le proprietà meccaniche
dei materiali delle piante le strategie
che mettono in atto per ridurre il
consumo energetico durante i movimenti
ma anche le strategie di adattamento
all'ambiente tutte queste
caratteristiche sono oggetto di studio e
vogliamo tradurle in tecnologia in
particolare ci siamo focalizzati sulle
radici
le radici sono assolutamente delle
strutture affascinanti che si muovono in
un ambiente molto complessa eterogeneo
come il suolo dove pressioni ed attriti
sono già elevati in pochi centimetri ma
le radici riescono a muoversi perché
crescono crescono dalla punta la parte
più distale rispetto al tronco crescono
per aggiunta di cellule poi assorbono
l'acqua dal suolo e spingono solo la
punta l'apice radicale il resto della
radice non si muove nel suolo quindi non
c'è attrito e al livello delle punte
le radici anno
sofisticate capacità sensoriali riescono
a percepire l'ambiente gravità luce
temperature sostanza chimiche e hanno un
comportamento associato a queste
capacità sensoriali che in biologia
chiamiamo tropismo quindi le radici si
muovono crescendo da una parte o
dall'altra
seguono una stimolo si allontano da uno
stimolo e abbiamo cercato di tradurre
esattamente questo concetto della
crescita come un nuovo paradigma nella
robotica una radice è una pianta per
muoversi da un punto a un altro possono
solo crescere
allora abbiamo cercato di tradurre
questo concetto della del movimento
nella nella robotica quindi anche il
nostro robot è in grado di crescere per
aggiunta di materiale e lo fa perché
nella punta vi è un motore che tira un
filamento termoplastico quindi che
cambia le sue proprietà viscose quando è
riscaldato e il nuovo strato aderisce a
quello precedente quindi i robot crea la
sua struttura
la direzione di crescita è data dai
sensori che sono integrati nella punta
quindi anche il nostro robot come la
radice naturale riesce a muoversi
crescendo e a muoversi verso lontano da
uno stimolo ambientale per curvare il
robot deposita più materiale da una
parte rispetto all'altra quindi
implementa quelle che vengono chiamate
crescita differenziale proprio come le
radici naturali ma sono molti i
movimenti in realtà che possiamo
studiare nelle piante molte di questi
movimenti sono totalmente passivi ovvero
non si muovono non c'è un metabolismo
all'interno ma queste strutture si
muovono grazie alla struttura del
materiale all'interno della parete
cellulare di queste piante e la capacità
di questi materiali di interagire con
l'ambiente circostante e soprattutto
variazione
merita e temperatura quindi dei
materiali che assorbono e rilasciano
l'acqua ed è materiale che a seconda di
come sono distribuite guidano il
movimento delle piante
allora una pigna che si apre e si chiude
un seme di acero che vola un seme di
avena che penetra nel suolo
tutti questi movimenti sono movimenti e
strutture assolutamente morte ma che
continuano a muoversi grazie
all'interazione con l'ambiente
circostante
allora la nostra idea è stata quella di
tradurre questi materiali in strutture
artificiali che analogamente le naturale
si muovano grazie all'interazione con
l'ambiente quindi una mano robotica per
afferrare degli oggetti delle strutture
che si aprono e si chiudono tutte queste
strutture potrebbero essere utili domani
anche come una pelle artificiale dei
nostri robot che percepiscono l'ambiente
ridurre riducendo la complessità del
controllo e soprattutto il consumo
energetico
questa è una visione del del plant o ed
il plant o ed è anche nella sua
apparenza simile ad una pianta a un
tronco all'interno del quale mettiamo il
materiale da depositare nelle radici a
una serie di rami con questi materiali
che interagiscono con l'ambiente
circostante e una serie di radici che
come dicevo crescono muovendosi
allontanandosi da degli stimoli
ambientali perché il robot in autonomia
in completa autonomia riesce a muoversi
nell'ambiente alla ricerca di sostanze
di interesse quindi ad esempio la
ricerca dell'acqua è un tropismo
positivo il robot si muove verso lo
stimolo evita però gli ostacoli come
fanno le radici naturali hanno dei
sensori tattili in punta quando vi sono
dei sassi
oppure non riescono a penetrare la
pianta gira intorno all'ostacolo allora
la crescita el altro aspetto
fondamentale per la prima volta un robot
è in grado di creare il proprio corpo
e di adattarsi all'ambiente circostante
questa è la vera rivoluzione che
vogliamo portare nel mondo della
robotica
ma cosa serve un planetoide a seconda
dei sensori che noi introduciamo nella
punta il robot ad esempio potrebbe
servire per il monitoraggio
dell'ambiente potrebbe andare alla
ricerca dell'acqua di sostanze
pericolose come inquinanti radon
assolutamente pericolosi per la salute
umana ma potrebbe essere utile anche
nello spazio ad esempio alla ricerca di
nuove sostanze in pianeti diversi dalla
terra ma quello che è importante che le
piante quando si ancorano praticamente
alla superficie consentono poi alla
pianta di crescere l'ancoraggio è un
problema aperto in robotica quindi
potrebbe essere utile anche in ambito
spaziale nel futuro potrebbe essere
utile anche come nuovo endoscopio perché
questa capacità di crescere all'interno
dei tessuti senza creare danni ai nostro
il nostro corpo ai nostri organi
potrebbe essere proprio una nuova
frontiera quindi rilasciando ad esempio
sostanze come farmaci oppure andando
alla ricerca di target di interesse
medico allora quello che possiamo vedere
guardandoci intorno nel mondo che ci
circonda e che forse non siamo proprio
così lontani da un uso di massa
quotidiano dei robot
molte sono le sfide che ancora ci
attendono soprattutto nello sviluppo di
robot più efficienti ma la vera sfida è
quella di capire quali sono le reali
opportunità e le reali responsabilità
nello sviluppo di questi robot
soprattutto prevedere l'impatto che
questi robot e avranno nel futuro nel
miglioramento della qualità della vita
allora personalmente quello che io ho
capito dallo sviluppo del clan tojo è
che le buone idee da sole non bastano
occorre anche analisi critica
perseveranza determinazione ma anche
collaborazione la valorizzazione della
diversità diverse discipline che si
uniscono nella multi disciplinarietà che
rappresenta il vero valore il progresso
come riusciamo andare oltre la
conoscenza alla scienza ha anche un
altro ruolo fondamentale nella società
quello di formare le nuove generazioni
i nuovi talenti aprire le loro menti
liberarli dal pregiudizio perché nuova
conoscenza il nuovo progresso
siamo sempre di più sinonimo anche di
rispetto dell'altro del diverso e di
altre forme di vita grazie
[Applauso]